the pearl of the Caribbean has long been
known for its vintage American cars
spicy salsa music and revolutionary
heroes the country's had a lot of
high-profile visitors lately after the
Pope and the Obama family
here come the Rolling Stones workers
have been building the concert stage for
The Rock Giants for weeks it's shaping
up to be a spectacle the likes of which
Cuba's never seen before
Eduardo diono is one of Cuba's
best-known independent filmmakers he's
also a big Rolling Stones fan Kousaka
Daniel sweaty and below if you were
lucky you could watch these things on
video or on TV at home but to be right
here to be present at this live concert
and to know what's going to be film and
that the stones are really going to be
here and perform for us it's a fantastic
feeling we're going to see one of the
biggest bands in the history of rock and
roll rock and roll has not always been
welcome in Cuba
on the contrary antecedent
in the 1960s and 70s the authorities
used to associate rock music especially
the anglo-saxon variety with the enemy
anything sung in English was considered
the language of the enemy of the state
no other Cuban is as well versed in rock
music
as Maria Beth Or no who's considered the
godmother of Cuba's rock scene she
struggled for decades to establish a
free and uncensored music culture on the
island these days she's working with
Cuba's younger generation as director of
the state-run rock agency potent
elemental Ovid mi fuerza Cato mucho
unfortunately life has more vitality
right now than ever and times have
changed from the days when rock was
banned and even scorned sama we go and
that's all thanks to the Cuban rock
agency and the maxime Rock Center except
100 row what do young local musicians
know about the Rolling Stones that's a
question for these rockers who like
listening to music on their smartphones
when they're not playing on the weekends
in Havana Park what do they make of the
stones upcoming concert the biggest
music event we've ever had
Obama's visit is important too it's
going to bring a lot of change to the
country this is the greatest
it's a world-famous group and they're
coming to this country where there's
practically no culture it feels good to
be included what would she say to all
this for one night the original rock
star of revolution will be upstaged by
movers and shakers from another part of
the world